on screen
there are many great resonances about
being an actor
one of my first attractions to acting
was that I could forget about Patrick
Stewart
to not be Patrick Stewart if only for a
few hours a week
was such a relief
and there was a price to pay
for that
the knighted Shakespearean captain of
Starship Enterprise international
treasure and master Storyteller is here
in the house and he brings with him
conversational Delights lifted from his
83 years of life we have Tales from his
humble beginnings we talk about how the
theater saved him and how childhood
trauma informed his career which of
course led us into a deep dive on Mental
Health generally and his passion for
mental health advocacy we also talk
about friendship particularly the nature
of his beautiful friendship with sir Ian
McKellen we discuss Legacy longevity
craft mentorship and why Star Trek is
just so indelible which of course led to
brief thoughts on UFOs and also this
incredible story about the ghost that he
is absolutely convinced to up resonance
in his Silver Lake home all of these
stories and themes are more fully
elaborated in sir Patrick's wonderful
new Memoir making it so
as long time Trekkie this one was a
dream I hope you enjoy it as much as I
did so here we go this is me and Sir
Patrick
[Music]
you look amazing I'm thrilled to have
you here uh you don't look a day older
than you look in Star Trek next
Generation I I want to know what your
longevity secrets are you're so spry and
with it and funny and present and
fit there's got to be some secrets look
that's it staying plugged in well it has
been for me in that
life as opposed to work can get quite
complicated in our business you know the
hours are long
it could be anywhere in any corner of
the world I came from a very work
conscious background
um
my father
was proud of of what he did Even though
as it you may have seen in the book that
he um
the highlight of his career was the
second world war 10 years in India in
the 20s
the moment he heard my mother was
pregnant he took off
and he ended his military career
at the end of 1945
as a regimental sergeant major of the
parachute regiment
and uh that meant everything to him he
was very very proud of that one day a
guy just after my father had died he um
I met him in a pub and he said I know
you you're Al Stewart's son and I said
yeah that's right and he said your dad
you know
when he walked on a parade ground the
birds and the trees stopped singing
what do you make of that what does that
mean
presence I think I mean
I know what it means as an actor
that I know mostly that from watching
other actors and you know somebody walks
on stage and you go
oh my God now I don't know why that
happens but there is a
there is focus concentration
and intensity a gravity objectives
that make them
and other people yeah you forget they're
there yeah sometimes no you know those
people when they walk into the room the
the sense of weight and Charisma and
gravitas that he obviously earned and
and what you just shared uh you know has
a sensibility of of kind of reverence
and and respect for who he was but he
was a he was a challenging guy as well
he was not a he was not an easy guy to
grow up underneath oh no
I I mean he first came home when I was
about 15 months old and I have no
recollection of that
and one more time I think in 1943 he
came home when I was probably four
and I just have memories of a man in a
uniform looking
kind of exciting I thought at the time
no the problems began when the war ended
and
um his his Colonel said so what are you
going to do Sergeant when uh
you know when you get back home and my
father said oh I've got a job and he
said well
that's what I wanted to talk to you
about and he explained that
he had contact at the Dorchester hotel
in London now the Dorchester is one of
the top four or five hotels historic
hotels in London famous for its high tea
that's right yeah which by the way I
recommend if I've ever done it once
you've done it once good for you yeah
Americans love it it's great and uh
he said they uh there is a vacancy
coming up in a few weeks for a doorman
an assistant doorman
but the doorman
is going to be retiring in two years
time
and his job would be yours Alpha and uh
he's and my father said well that's
great and there was a
an apartment that came with the job in
the hotel wow they said you're married
on you and he said yes and he they said
well we'll employ your wife too she
could get a job in the hotel as well I
mean it sounded wonderful and my wife my
wife his wife my mother said nope
I'm not leaving West Yorkshire this had
been my home all her life and it had it
had in fact that the little town we
lived in a population of nine thousand
and it has its own wild dialect that's
indecipherable to most of us right using
words
yeah I mean it's crazy the way that you
grew up speaking Yeah yeah
um I was not allowed to say thee and
thou to my father though
but I I mean as a as a child that
playing and uh you know you could say to
people thee which was always critical in
some way
or uh or that was was the way that we
shortened it
that doesn't understand lad
you know that I don't know I don't know
what they're talking about so there was
this
semi ancient speech that was ours and in
fact
I spoke a strong dialect when I was a
child and
when I was 13 I had to lose it because
can you bring it back at all
my family have always told me oh you
can't do Yorkshire anymore no you you
changed your act and I did I learned a
new accent which was RP received a
pronunciation
uh classical BBC News time English not
anymore because now they deliberately
employ people with accents and and the
world has become a more relaxed and
easier place in many respects some of
them not good and um it's it it's it's a
better time but back then
um
well let me think of anything I could
say okay uh there's a very simple one
when I would go to a friend's house
he would open the door and I would say I
don't lick it out
translate that for me I have no idea
Art Thou
Lakin 15th century word for playing
actors in Shakespeare's day were called
Lakers
wow not
um that's kind of amazing the Los
Angeles Lakers double entender there
that's super interesting well it's it's
certainly a 14th century word it could
be um
out are you coming out to play is the
translation so it was it was dialect it
wasn't accent alone I would go home to
my family and they would say
you're not a Yorkshire ladder anymore
not anymore you know it sounds good yeah
yeah that's right yeah disowned
um my mother liked it because she liked
to hear me speaking very very Grand you
know when I had an accent like this
which was very very cultured and very
professional and sophisticated
um I don't talk like that right right
um back to your your dad a little bit I
mean you spoke about you know some of
the things that he did in World War II I
mean this was a guy who you know ended
up I think he was he airlifted out of
Sherborn like around uh Dunkirk right
yeah so this guy had done a lot he's
they'd already evacuated and like doing
some some pretty ballsy crazy stuff but
he comes home
finds himself back in Yorkshire and you
know it's pretty it's pretty easy to
kind of identify what was going on with
him now given what we understand about
what happens with veterans when they
return from conflict zones yes but at
that time it was just shell shock nobody
understood it and of course with that
there's domestic violence there's
alcohol abuse and you know a whole you
know array of sorted behaviors that uh
you were on the kind of receiving end of
as a as a young person yes
um at the hands of my father unlike my
Headmaster I didn't receive personally
any violence he would raised his hand
several times and the moment that he did
that I wouldn't freeze and become
something that he wasn't going to hit
um
he beat my brother
and he did it in front of me and my
brother who was five years older than me
I was the baby of the family
and uh
it was uh
appalling
and
I mean I've only subsequently learned I
I did a television program for the BBC
quite a few years ago now and and they
had a specialist of PTSD on the show and
um he he'd been told about my father and
then he talked to me and he said
he was ill
and if it's possible at all for you to
allow that
to become part of your recollection of
your unpleasant childhood
um he was sick
and could not control himself so it was
a mental condition as much as anything
and he was angry and
I always thought that once I heard this
story about the Dorchester hotel that he
was he never ceased to be angry with my
mother because he knew that that job
would have been perfect for him because
he was smart he had conversation and he
could talk he had language and then he
had this dialect which was people loved
here they thought it was Charming he
would have been a star
standing in the front door of the
Dorchester Hotel yeah so he held on to a
certain resentment took out his
frustration on the people that he cared
about and it's it's interesting to hear
you share that because with that
realization that this was an illness
that he was a victim of something he had
no control over allows you to then have
compassion not only for your mother as a
as a you know victim of domestic abuse
but also for the perpetrator
to have some kind of empathy for why he
ended up behaving that way which in turn
gives you a certain Freedom you're
liberated from holding on to your anger
around that and I know it wasn't I mean
I don't think you shared that publicly
until maybe
2010 or something like that you held on
to that for a long time yeah for a very
long time I was ashamed
and I was ashamed that I couldn't
impact
what was so awful about my home life
I couldn't change it did you blame
yourself
yeah
yeah and so you know that my elder
brother did yeah yeah because you were
the younger if anyone was gonna feel
like he needed to you know make it
better for you it would be him yeah yeah
he was and he he he only died last year
um
and he took care of me
and If Ever I was at any risk he would
protect me
and then as I got older and I wanted to
do all the things he did play soccer
with him and his friends play cricket
with him and his friends and of course
he didn't want his kid brother to be
hanging out with us at all because he
was five years older than me they all
were you know and uh
he he nevertheless always had an eye for
me and I only went into therapy
um
about
the 90s
I'd never done in what was the
revelation of engaging with therapy
well one of the things I learned was how
to listen
because she mostly listened
I mean when she did talk she would say
tell me
how
in what way and and so that if she was
always inviting me to contribute the
conversations but then as my time
without it was for several years went on
um
we began to talk about mental issues
mental disturbances
bouts of anger I still occasionally get
them
and I'm sure no I know where it comes
from yeah um it happened only a few days
ago I'm ashamed to say and um
well uh I had read that
um there was an article a couple years
ago that said that at eight you're 83
now right 8 at 80 you were still in
therapy are you still in therapy now
no I'm not you're not except cured
except for the occasional angry
outbursts
um they don't happen very often they're
quite rare I'm relieved to say
um but no I I I have two therapists now
but I see them
when I feel that there is a need rather
than it's not a daily or weekly event
for me I'm interested in the
relationship between that childhood
Dynamic and and your your burgeoning
relationship with the theater it feels
like the theater is really what saved
you finding yourself amongst a community
of of like-minded people at an early age
becomes this true salvation for your for
your life and you had a couple
instrumental teachers and and mentors
that kind of guided you and nudged you
in that direction saw something in you
very early on
there are many
for me great
resonances about being an actor
and one of the strongest is the people I
encounter
finding that there were in the world
other young people and some of them
significantly older
who
um
felt the same kind of isolation that I
felt
and yet in the company of actors there
was an almost intuitive connection that
was made between us and I was 12 years
old when I first was dumped into a a
large group of actors on a course that
was run it was a brand new course run by
the West riding County Council in
Yorkshire and the minimum age was 14 and
it was in my headmaster's office that I
met a man called Gerald Tyler he's in
the book and he had come to say that the
um
the County Council were going to run an
eight-day
theater course a residential theater
course by that it meant we had Camp beds
to lie on in School classrooms but
nevertheless from the moment that I
arrived there I was in the company
of people like me now some of them were
highly educated I mean I got a big crush
on a girl who's at grammar school but it
didn't work out I was the second remote
um and and yet
it was a love of acting performing of
plays scripts texts
um
uh being in front of an audience which
Never Scared me ever at all
and there was a reason for this
um
one of my first attractions to acting
was
that I could forget about Patrick
Stewart right that was my next question
how much of this aside from finding
like-minded people in this tribe of
young artists how much of it was an
escape from your own life or the uh
opportunity to step outside who you were
and just become somebody altogether
different as a defense mechanism and not
having to deal with whatever pain is
kind of lingering in your subconscious
you uh
explain it perfectly yeah that's exactly
how it was to not be Patrick Stewart's
if only for a few hours a week
was such a relief
to explore being someone other than
myself with a different background I
mean the first role that I played other
than this um this thing that we've done
about the history of Yorkshire and
mirfield where I grew up
um
was a company called
the happiest days of your life you may
have encountered it very occasionally it
crops up into the ferry occasionally
and it was all set in a private boys
school a rather exclusive private boy
school and it was wartime and a private
girls school had been found places in
the school so there were now boys and
girls playing there and I played a
character you see I remember his name
called hopcroft Miner
he had an older brother who was hopcroft
and um
and it was such a joy to be playing an
upper-class child even though I
struggled with the accident I didn't
really have a
proper received pronunciation accent
until I was 15 or 16. but I was learning
I was and and sometimes it made people
laugh when they heard me speak because
it sounded so portentous and uh you know
um
so becoming someone else
that was the main attraction yeah and I
could forget who Patrick Stewart was but
but not with any self-awareness around
that
it's not as if you understood I mean a
young person wouldn't wouldn't be
expected to understand that oh I'm doing
this because I'm trying to you know get
away from this other thing but you do
have a moment when
um when you were doing
the Macbeth rendering that was set in a
Cold War era where you connected the
dots between
your your kind of actor sensibility and
this character that you were inhabiting
tracing it back to your father do you
know the story I'm I'm referring to yeah
I do it was
um
a great invitation to be offered that
role
um
by a wonderful actor called Rupert Gould
who was just starting out then but is
now very well established in the UK
um and he's done a couple of films as
well we both felt that
I mean if you're interested in the
theater you know who Macbeth is and what
he did yeah
so we wanted to put him into a context
in which
what it was was understandable
and that was intriguing
um and I I did go and talk to a lot of
people and uh about the because he is
Macbeth is ill and gets iller as the
play goes on
um
that you remember the story I told in
the book about running into Ian McKellen
in the yeah in the chairman Crossroad
one day and he said so how's it going
there Macbeth
and uh oh God I was so uncomfortable
because Ian was the Macbeth of my
generation him and Judy Dench who played
Lady Macbeth I saw that production and
Trevor non-directed it and it was
amazing and the cast just sat in a
circle around a quite small Studio stage
and just stood up when that turn came so
it had an intimacy about it but um and
then Ian said to me um oh um if I can
there's there's just one thing I'd like
to mention about playing Macbeth and I
said anything at all please and he said
okay
um the line that begins the famous
speech tomorrow and tomorrow and
tomorrow Creeps in this Petty Pace from
day to day
he said the most important word in that
first line
is and
and I had it in a Flash I knew exactly
what he meant
tomorrow
and tomorrow
and tomorrow Creeps in this Petty and
you're rolling then you're rolling
he unlocked it for you oh not not just
that speech but it spread into the rest
of the play and I knew
that Macbeth
was inside me mm-hmm
but it's when you dress up in the
costuming of the character and look in
the mirror and you have this Epiphany
yes yes
um
the First dress rehearsal
um I'd grown a mustache quite a
heavyweight mustache unlike my father's
who had a uh you know um very very
narrow small Sergeant Major's mustache
and um
I was in uniform
uh and it was the end of a battle we
were coming from a battle
myself from Banquo and I had an Overcoat
on
and I had a military cap pulled down
over my face and a rifle slung over my
shoulder
um
and uh I was just getting these things
on the dresser was helping me and then
she said have a look in the mercy you
think
and my father was looking back at me
unmistakable him
and it gave me quite a shock
but then I saw the advantage of this
I knew him he wasn't inside me
other than he had been my father
and that allowed me
to embrace him and bring him in and feel
about him both his
rages and his
fear and his sadness
and the pain that he'd had because he'd
had he'd been wounded several times
fortunately never
very seriously
um but he had been wounded and of course
he jumped out of airplanes yeah well
just fascinating from the perspective of
kind of unconsciously inhabiting this
character and then finally realizing
like oh this is what I was doing you
know and and being able to connect with
that and develop a greater understanding
of this complicated person yeah and and
also understanding that on some level he
contributed to your skill as an actor
through that process
is kind of amazing
I wish that I could have told him
exactly what you said
he got to see you succeed he passed away
shortly before next Generation though is
that right yes yes he did yeah and he
would have loved Next Generation
particularly that I was Captain Picard
um because he was always a
non-commissioned officer although he
became the highest ranking
non-commissioned officer he was a field
Marshal of non-commissioned officers
yeah you playing a military officer with
with with great integrity would have
appealed to him yeah yeah it it really
would but then you know as time went by
I discovered that there was
uh and under the covers aspects to
Picard as well and
um when we came to do the new series
Picard
um we really examined that because
the writers and directors were very
interested in uncovering
a man that we had seen almost nothing
off there was one scene in one episode
when I screamed I yelled at a woman and
I threw something at a glass fronted
I don't know cocktail cabinet or
something and shattered it and and
and this was shocking for people they'd
never seen Jean-Luc Picard like this
but I knew how to do it yeah and uh it's
inside you
it was inside you the whole time
yeah it's um
and there was a price to pay for that
in rehearsals
um I just delved into all of that and
put it into the role
[Music]
um
by then I had uh two divorces and
I was to blame for both of them
I watched the first uh episode of of
Picard from season one the other night
and I was really struck by there's that
scene where you're being interviewed and
your buttons get pushed and then the you
know the the you you kind of unleash
right and it reminded me of it was very
similar to the uh Jack Nicholson uh
Sorkin scene in A Few Good Men Colonel
Jessup you know being being provoked
just enough to let the lion out you know
like you know
saying you want me on that wall you need
me on that wall like did you order the
code red you're goddamn right I ordered
the coke the code red like that speech
that you give is is very resonant of it
reminded me of that
in there and it's like that there's that
latent you know
uh not necessarily anger a little
self-righteousness earned through
experience yeah
um the other the other kind of example
of that for me was when you did
um when you were leontes in in Winter's
Tale right which is kind of a watershed
moment in you kind of Reckoning with
your past
yes it was and um
it it was uh
very challenging when I read the play
first of all I'd seen the play and found
it interesting but not it didn't appeal
to me in the way that so much of
Shakespeare did
one day I uh I was in The Green Room of
the royal Shakespeare theater so I was
working there and uh I I had I've been
made this offer of leontes in the
Winter's Tale and sitting alone at a
table was Dan Peggy Ashcroft whom I
didn't know but she was a member of the
company but I wasn't in the place she
was in and I said
I sit by you and she said yes of course
come on sit down and um and we had a
chat and I said look
um I've got to ask you this I've been
offered leontes in Winter's Tale and I
saw her face change straight away and um
I I said I
I I don't know what to do about it I
don't could you give me any help or
advice and she said turn it down don't
do it don't do it
he's a bad bad man and nobody likes him
the audience don't like him because he's
vile to everybody there's nobody who's
on his side except of course there's one
good friend whom he kills
and um
I
I I I I said to her thank you you've
articulated what I think I was feeling
so that's great and then the director
said well have you made a decision and I
said yes I have and I'm going to pass
and he said tell me why so I did
and he said can we meet just one more
time and talk
and so we did and um
he said you see Patrick the reason why
I'm so determined
to have you play this character is that
you're not going to have to interpret
him he's already inside you
I know that
I don't know how he knew it yeah what do
you think he saw that made him say that
I don't know but he was a psychologist
also right he is yes yes he is Ronald
air is his name and yes he is
um brilliant brilliant man and he said
if you do it I give you my word I will
never leave your side
not one moment I will be there there and
he was too and boy
it was hard it was really hard
um
but one thing that came out of it I'm so
grateful for
um and I looked at it this morning and
adjusted it there is a photo on my desk
off Winter's Tale of me as leontes and
my dear beloved friend Bernard Lloyd
we have been talking to him and I've
been going crazy in the character and
and they were taking photos it was a
photo shoot but they wanted action they
wanted the real play and in this
photograph
he has his hand on my arm and he's
leaning towards me and there is so much
gentleness in his face so much empathy
and sympathy
that when I
was first shown that photograph
I knew it was for all time and it's been
on my desk in a frame ever since then
because
that was
that became the symbol of what
kindness and friendship could mean in a
in a relationship because I had not been
too good at that in my adult life and um
and then Bernie died uh actually
probably two years ago now
and I was with him
um
until quite close to his death and
he um
he was very stiff and hurting and my
wife said Sonny said can I can I just
give you a little massage I think I
think it might help you and he said yes
okay okay and he stretched out and she
massaged him for half an hour
and then she hugged him and then I
hugged him and we left and we got to our
car
and we burst into tears
both of us so that picture of him
touching my arm with such kindness is
part of my daily life yeah that's
beautiful thank you for sharing that I
mean I think what I what I extracted or
or took from that story and your
experience of doing Winter's Tale was
that you have this director who's also a
psychologist who identified something in
your psyche that needed to come out that
would contribute to the performance and
make it great and terrifying and you
know I know there are stories of people
in the audience who felt like we
shouldn't even be watching this it was
so intense absolutely but from a
psychologist's point of view
it's almost ingenious that he it was a
form of therapy for you to connect with
that part to realize that that piece of
your dad is inside of you or there's
that unhealed uh you know pain that
resides in inside of you from that
experience growing up that still
required you to to you know reckon with
it and and look at it and and perhaps
that was a piece in the puzzle that led
you towards therapy and and kind of
making peace with this that has on some
level you know healed those wounds
that's very true and it it was something
that I could absorb into my work into my
acting and my approach to bringing a
role to life
um
uh always great play I think the Great
American player of the 20th century I'm
sorry Mr Miller
he wrote a play called who's Afraid of
Virginia and
um
I got to play George
the husband it's a couple two couples a
husband and wife who are middle-aged and
a young married couple with a tinge of
alcoholism sprinkled in oh Lord yes
so much liquor in that
yeah and I had some experience of that
too
um
but my two broken marriages
I realized gave me an
uh profound sense of what had been going
on inside me during that time when the
marriages were breaking up and that I
could absorb them into George
I have another photograph that sits on
my desk and it's uh
it is I I because it's going to be in
the book when the photographs are put
into the book it will be there yeah I've
just got the galley here so I don't even
have the final one it's not out yet
um there's it's quite a collection of
photographs it will surprise people
which is good yeah I'm looking forward
to that especially my childhood
photographs
um but in in this one I'm playing George
and it's a scene when Martha his wife
actually isn't on the stage
um it's a scene in the last Act of the
play and uh
I I when I was wearing a wig a thinning
hair but some of the hair was danging
over my forehead and
my head is down and I look so depressed
and fearful
and I I know that that was authentic
because I was able to tap into
those feelings that I had when I when I
was getting
my first divorce
and we were living apart and I went to
bed at night
and this is the only time this has ever
happened for me I was in so much Terror
that my legs sweated just my legs
nothing else at all and I've heard that
that can happen but it was an indication
of what was inside me well one of the
one of the great Joys including
Captain Jean-Luc Picard is that having
to immerse yourself into someone else
can be so rich in lessons and learning
and understanding and
getting closer to other people as well
yeah well it breeds empathy you're
literally walking a mile in someone
else's shoes
yes and it changes your your view of
humanity I suspect yeah yeah yeah when I
was doing Macbeth I did it for exactly
365 days the first and the last before
us
for a whole year I played that guy I
lived that guy
and it became not good for me I mean for
one thing I began drinking only out when
the show was over too much way too much
and um I I his depressions and ferocity
and despair towards the end of the play
would begin to envelop me more and more
as the evening or or matony days when we
do it twice war on and
um
it it
became
difficult how do you create healthy
boundaries around that so it doesn't
seep in and I guess it sounds like
that's been a challenge for you
if you end up uh you know drinking a
little bit too much and you know walking
around booting on on this character that
you're inhabiting I've learned and sunny
my wife has helped me with this
that when I've finished a day on the set
it doesn't happen that often with
filming but it can do but certainly when
I come home from playing a stage roll
I deliberately Let It Go
Let It Go I mean this is the gesture
that I use Shake It Out
now I can go home and have some supper
and not be an absolute [__] misery
well this is what I was has to be an
insane High to do that every night and
then you're supposed to just go home and
go to bed when your hormones are going
crazy because you've just done this
endurance event this artistic endurance
event you know in real time in front of
a live audience who then receives you
and you're you're feeling that you know
energy of the crowd and then you just
you're supposed to just go to sleep
after that like I don't know how that
works and the last I'm always amazed at
Broadway actors who just get up every
night or sometimes twice a night and do
that for incredibly long stretches oh
it's unbelievable yeah I I have a limit
now on how long I can do a playful
particularly if it's a play that I know
is going to be sucking me in yeah what's
interesting is before the podcast you
were sharing about how you just recorded
the audiobook for this and you said that
was one of if not the most difficult
things that you've done most as a
performer no question most difficult
compared to being on Broadway every
night
or 20-hour days on Star Trek I've
already told you why
I'm being myself
that's really hard
yeah I wrote it and I had no intention
of reading out loud recording it when oh
come on of course you're going to read
your audiobook believe me it came as a
shock
you think somebody else is going to
voice you you in Europe I don't listen
to audiobooks I've never heard an audio
book I've never recorded one before I
mean people get sent you ought to do it
you know it can be fun and you know it's
interesting
no I never wanted to do it and uh so it
was in my contract and it was only when
I got around to reading the contract in
detail that I saw that I was also
committing to an audiobook
but some Schuster and particularly
Christina the producer that I work with
on the audiobook has been fantastic I I
can only do about two hours I once or
twice gotten close to three and I've
once wrapped after an hour because it
just destroyed me it wore me out doing
it it's so difficult I met two actors
who said let's give you a warning if
you've never done an audio book before
it is the hardest work you'll ever do
and I said but you're sitting down with
a microphone a few inches I've got to be
hard they said well if you do it you can
wait and see
I think people would be aghast if you
didn't end up voicing the audiobook to
this it would be it just would not be
right well I'm doing it every morning
and that's one of the reasons why my
voice is a little Gravelly
um because
um I don't know what it is it's what I'm
putting into the morning's work that I
and I only ever stop recording when I
think it's time for my my voice to be
rested you know well you sound great you
mentioned uh you mentioned friendship a
little bit earlier that photograph
that's on your desk
um
which leads me to my curiosity around
your your friendship with Ian McKellen
which you know I think we can all agree
this is this is friend friend goals for
all of us like it's such a beautiful
um relationship that you have with this
with this person uh it motivated me to
go on the internet and and kind of find
pictures of him as a young man because
you describe him as just there's a
Mythos around who this person was even
when he was young you know many decades
ago uh that that just portrays him as
larger than life and and sure enough I
mean the the images of him as a young
man are just absolutely striking
beautiful yeah but he was somebody who
was very intimidating to Everybody
Somebody everybody knew was going to be
on the rise and I think there's this
idea that the two of you had been
friends from the get-go but that is not
the case no no no no no
um we I first met him at the Royal
Shakespeare company but we never work
together
only some years later we worked once we
did a Tom stop art play called Every
Good Boy Deserves favor
egbdf and
um Ian was in it and uh I I I I was very
shy of him what was it about him
it was the way he listened when you
talked to him
because Ian is known as a talker himself
but he is a wonderful listener
and uh
I talked to him about things I'd never
talked to another man about before yeah
he said you said that uh you blame him
for turning you into a child again
what does that mean
um
well I I became silly and adventurous
and playful and of course he is you know
he's got a great sense of humor and uh
and a great sense of irony particularly
um and so
egbdf was one thing and John Ward and
Ian McAllen were the two leading actors
I just simply played a psychiatrist
um I should be so lucky and um
Ian
um
I I don't know how to
I've tried I've sat in front of my
computer for a long time sometimes
thinking about about Ian and the the
affection that I have for him and what
he gave me when we work together and
when I watched him work on stage
um and and now in in our friendship it's
it's
close to a love affair As I Shall ever
have with a man yeah
I I don't know if you know this but if
you Google
Ian McKellen Patrick Stewart one of the
first things that pops up is this
question is Ian McKellen married to
Patrick Stewart
[Laughter]
sorry behind that do you know what I'm
referring to yeah so so at one point
yourself Ian and Hugh Jackman all appear
on The Graham Norton Show and Ian
announces that he is going to marry you
so there's there's there's there's what
he actually meant and there's how that
was interpreted that's right
he was the priest at our wedding and he
was he was he had been qualified and uh
and um so far as I know Sonny and I were
only the only couple he married although
he had multiple offers once the word got
around that uh he was uh I have no doubt
yeah so he ends up marrying you I guess
you were going to get married in Nevada
but there there was a pesky state law
around his his his ministry his his sort
of legal uh you know it was not
recognized in Nevada
and so we would we would go through a
mockery of a wedding so I think I think
as I understood the story uh yeah you
were you were in Lake Tahoe you were
going to get married on the Nevada side
but he wasn't legally permitted to do
that so you all crossed the border into
California and did an impromptu ceremony
in a Mexican restaurant in a Mexican
restaurant at 11 o'clock at night yeah
and just like a small group of you right
yeah yeah oh there were five of us hmm
um so we had Witnesses too
um and uh it it it it
was extraordinary
um
let's talk about Star Trek what
do you remember that part of your life
it's hard to be a blur though most of
it's got to be one big blur oh yes
we recorded over
um how many seasons Chris swaddle now
seven seasons we did something like 174
episodes uh-huh
and there are only a handful of them I
remember yeah the rest of just all gone
into the Melting Pot
and but there are some vivid
Recollections I do have of certain
episodes and certain actors that I
worked with and uh what that meant to me
and and the fact that I was getting a a
break in
popular
TV sure yeah I mean this was a big deal
you were you were I think it was uh
was it LeVar Burton who put a sign on
your door that said something like
beware uh unknown British Shakespearean
actor inside like this was your
introduction I mean you went from being
this you know just a theater person into
the public Consciousness very quickly
and the story behind how you got Star
Trek which you go into in detail in the
book is is super fascinating I know Ian
told you not to do it he was trying to
talk you out of it yep he did he was the
only one who did
um he's apologized for that yeah
he was wrong
hahaha
it's interesting and and interesting to
try to understand what makes Star Trek
such a special idea that has left such a
an indelible kind of Mark on our culture
and and why it continues to persist and
be so popular I think the strongest
thing is that it is a vision of the
future and it is a positive hopeful
vision of the future oh yes Dreadful
things happen have happened in Star Trek
but behind Gene roddenberry's
motivation for creating the the
the first series and then coming to work
with us was that he wanted to leave
behind a sense of positivity
and hopefulness and confidence and it's
the one thing that he talked about with
me
um and uh actually what he said was we I
I had lunch with him we only had two
meals together because we didn't have
actually much in common he played a lot
of golf and I don't play any golf at all
the first the first meeting with him
didn't go so well right he did not want
you for the role it was a disaster and
he hadn't invited me it was my encounter
with well Robert Justman had come to
UCLA to see a public lecturer which an
actress and myself were Illustrated with
extracts from plays Shakespeare plays
and uh he'd seen it and he went back to
the office the next morning and he said
we found our captain
and they said what are you talking about
and they said
um and Jim Rodman said oh come on get
him in this morning let's have a look at
him if he's you think he's that good and
so that I I got the phone call at nine
o'clock in the morning and I was in
Gene's office at 11 o'clock that day and
uh
he got out of his chair there were two
other men in the room including Robert
Justman who was the man who had been to
see the play the night before and was
blown away by it Gene stood up and shook
my hand
and then we talked for
seven or eight minutes
and then Gene said all right thank you
very much for coming to see us and uh it
was thanks thank you goodbye
and uh I left kind of relieved actually
that I was out of this weird atmosphere
but uh
six months later right I was gossed did
you have misgivings about being this
highbrow Shakespearean actor and and
dipping your toes into Network
television at the time I didn't know
what I was doing
I'd been in you've done TV yeah yeah
um I mean some of it I Claudius the
great BBC series about uh based on the
the two famous novels like Claudius and
Claudius the god
um I've been in that I'd done a series
about a policeman
um which only lasted one season
um and uh occasionally little bits of
plays would turn up and um but it was
not a career for me and I actually
wasn't that interested really the
theater was what I loved performance
being on stage night after night after
night and um
that changed yeah you really came to
embrace every aspect of it yes and I
love it today yeah film and television
and um
I'm worried that I may never get to do
it again oh I think you're gonna get to
do it do some more yeah I think you got
I think he got a little more in you
I think when I think about Star Trek you
know I grew up with the original
Star Trek Captain Kirk Spock and all of
that and yes there is a beautiful
optimism to it perhaps not utopian but
optimistic enough which I think serves
as a contrast to most science fiction
but also it's always been a show that
has been Fearless in terms of grappling
with social issues like that's always
been at the core of what the show is
about it gives you an opportunity
through allegory to explore
things that are going on in culture
currently that were that we're
struggling with I
I have to say and this will sound unkind
to maybe those who hear this
um working with Gene Roddenberry was not
easy
I mean he never directed an episode he
was the executive producer did every
every big decision had to get run
through him oh yeah as the Creator
absolutely yes I was very unconfident in
fact when I started writing the Memoir
um I thought oh
the people are really going to want to
hear me go on and on and on about Star
Trek and maybe X-Men too and I don't
think I want to that's not the most
interesting part of my career I mean
that is a shocking thing to say because
it's assumed of course that it is and uh
I think that uh
that throughout that first season I
really didn't know what I was doing I
didn't understand television technique
I'd never had a class in television in
in my drama school we didn't do film and
TV work at all because
you know nobody was expected to get it
because they were just film actors and
there wasn't that much television either
um
and then um
I
I was determined that I would do better
and I knew
even when I first saw it that I the best
thing that I was doing in the first
season was space
the final frontier that I got really
good at and why because I copied exactly
what bill has said Bill Shatner bill
yeah yes yes uh but the the the the
thing that's striking is when you're on
the bridge there is a
there is a theatricality to that in a
very practical sense it is a stage
there's a there's entrances and exits
and you have your you're sitting on
you're literally sitting on a throne yes
so there are there is a parallel that I
imagine as a stage actor you were able
to connect with and tap into
I mean it's very Elizabethan you're
absolutely right and um
uh it it as it became more and more like
that I began to feel more and more
comfortable well I my first film
was um it's in the book was
um two afternoons or two mornings work
in a film
starring Rod Steiger Rod Steiger was one
of my childhood Heroes I'd seen
um the porn The Pawn Broker I'd seen
um uh on the waterfall on the waterfront
yes and and absolutely loved them and uh
and so he learning that I was um
this was my first ever day in front of a
film camera he said what are you doing
for lunch and I said I I don't know what
do you do for lunch on a film set he
said oh you go there and you order your
lunch and they'll give it to you bring
it to my trailer
Rod Steiger is inviting me into his
trailer The Man Who said
take the job
take the job right in the back of that
car with uh with um with Rod and uh and
um Brando Brando yeah but the the real
the real kicker to that story though is
it not uh the fact that you shot that
scene you shot a scene in the back of
the car with Rod Steiger for this movie
yeah I think you had to shoot him uh and
they were shooting all of his coverage
yeah and then when they finished that
they said lunch and then he threw a fit
yeah well they said uh what the actress
said was it did do all of Bill's
coverage some of which I was in and then
they said okay that's uh that's all we
need of you Bill uh you can go to lunch
now
right rod you mean yeah and uh we were
sitting side by side in the back of this
car I hadn't actually shot him or killed
him no I didn't yet
to do that
um he said
what about Patrick
and they said uh oh don't worry about
that we'll have somebody read in for you
and it'll all be fine
and there was a long silence and I could
feel this heat growing on one side of me
and he said
what the [__] do you think I am I mean
his voice going up and then he went for
this assistant stage manager and uh and
said you think you think I'm gonna leave
him now I just hold on my lines and I
I'm gonna leave him to do his own and uh
and anyway it was it was and then that
was when he said I'm sorry about he
apologized to me and I said no no no no
no no that was fine and he invited me to
his trailer and uh he said
the camera
photographs thoughts
no one had ever said that to me before
I mean that's the very heart of the
method
uh which he was a pupil I mean he he
studied just like Brando did so you
carrying that onto the the bridge of the
Starship Enterprise that sensibility of
the camera can read your thoughts and
also a leadership role as the captain
sitting in this round remembering that
Rod Steiger did what he did for this
young actor doing his first movie like
that that's a lesson right like this is
how you this is this is you know it's
not right like and if you're the lead in
a project the tone is being set by how
you comport yourself right and
understanding that you're now carrying
that responsibility exactly and it's one
of the reasons why I love playing the
leading role yeah because I feel that I
can help to give the other actors the
best possible experience they could have
and and I I will always say there are no
number one actors where an ensemble
we work together and I do remember
um one of the things rod always said Rod
said to me why on this lunchtime was
whoever is talking
he's the lead
whoever is
and that was amazing for us an actor who
only had half a dozen yeah he didn't
have to he didn't have to do that no he
didn't he was being kind and generous
and uh
oh boy and then you ran into him many
years later right years later and uh I
was in New York no I was here in Los
Angeles and I was I think already
working on Star Trek and I went to this
restaurant and we were looking around it
was very busy and there he was sitting
at a table with three other friends and
I said Son oh my God oh my God there's
Rod Steiger over there and she said go
and say hello go on I said oh okay okay
he won't know who the hell I am it was
years ago so I went over and before I
got to the table he said Patrick and
stood on bird and it was yeah one of the
best memories the gift that keeps giving
yeah right yeah beautiful I need to know
about the Paranormal Activity that was
happening in your silver lake house that
you talk about in the book oh yeah um
sounds like you were getting visited by
ghosts yeah I I bought a house on Moreno
Drive in Silver Lake one evening I came
home it was the floors were staggered
down a steep Hillside and so the door
from the garage LED straight into the
master bedroom
and uh one night I locked up the car
pulled down the door
opened the bedroom door
and the smell of cooking was intense and
I thought well I must have left the oven
on last night or why didn't I so God so
I hurried downstairs
nothing just the smell of cooking in the
air and nothing else at all
um and then it took on from there um
footsteps on the stairs
[Music]
um voices in rooms where there was
nobody
I came home one day my son was been
staying with me he went to school here
um and uh I I got home and he said oh
thank God you're home and I said why but
is something wrong he said
let me show you and we went into my
sitting room where I had a lot of
bookshelves and all the books were
thrown across were scattered across the
floor and I said what have you been
doing he said I didn't do anything I was
watching television and suddenly all
these books were thrown into the
earthquake button no earthquake
no earthquake no
um and there was a place in the hallway
which I used to go through the house
starting on the the the the ground floor
and then worked through my house turning
lights off and all that there was
because my television room was right on
the ground floor on the the lowest deck
of the house and I
when I got to the middle floor which was
the kitchen the living room and the
dining room and so forth
um I walked to the foot of the stairs
and just before I reached the stairs I
always walked through this icy Zone
it was just the temperature instantly
plummeted and I got to the foot one foot
on the step and it was gone
I rented the house when when after after
three years I moved somewhere else
um and uh I got a family moved into it
and they were lovely people and but one
day they called me to ask about I don't
know there was a problem with the
washing machine or something that had
gone wrong and and so we had a little
chat and then just as she was about to
hang up she said oh by the way Patrick
there's there was something I wanted to
ask you
you didn't tell us everything that came
with your house
they were having it worse than I was and
the child
exactly on this spot where I used to
feel the temperature plummet saw a man
standing there
and I found out about him I I became
very close to it my neighbors next door
and they'd lived there for decades
and they said yes yes
well that was a man who died in a car
accident actually
very violent car accident who had lived
in that house yes
what do you make of all this
well that's only one experience that
I've had I've been in other places when
I've just had
I mean I we Sonny and I were looking for
a house uh in England and um we went
into one and it was empty and all the
phones have been taken out but it was
very very old 15th 16th century and um
we were going along there was a long
Corridor in the upstairs floor and uh
there were doors of all the door off the
corridor into the rooms and I went into
one room and as I got into the middle of
the room I felt hands around my throat
and I cried out help help and Sonny came
and ran into the room and got hold of me
and dragged me out I was being strangled
in that room oh my god um so it's and
it's oh the first time I saw it I was 12
years old in a friend's in a neighbor's
house and
and uh so this is uh this is a recurring
thing
I I
I think I have
um some kind of
openness some kind of sensitivity
that Mayberry it's history I I don't
know but um I feel that I do hear voices
occasionally
and uh and and what do you choose to to
interpret from that what is your sense
of that I'm tuned in to the after world
and that there's no there's no mistake
or irony in you being uh an actor who
plays a character who goes and visits
with aliens I go over the Galaxy I don't
know maybe come on and then you turn on
the TV and there's Congressional
hearings on UFOs and and uaps like this
there's a convergence happening right
now what is going on Patrick there is
it's
extraordinary and things being seen more
and more in the sky I just hope that
whatever happens happens while I'm still
here yeah
um I gotta let you go shortly here but
uh there's two more things I want to
touch on quickly the first thing is is
is
uh you're a bit of an Animal Welfare
Advocate there's a couple squirrels that
appear and reappear in this book uh you
have an incident at a a bullfighting
match
um that seems like it was impactful and
I know you do a lot of work with dogs
particularly pit bulls yeah so where
does that
sense for animal well-being come from I
had a dog when my father bought me a dog
not long after he came out of the war
um the dog's name was Rover and he was a
thoroughbred
um
Scottish collie
a Scottish sheep dog he was black and
white very classical dog and I loved
this guy he was wonderful and we had him
a long long time and then he had to be
taken and put down he was very ill
um
but I I never forgot that and and um
when I I was I made contact by this um
Wags and walks in Los Angeles
um it opened all that up again and uh so
we began fostering
dogs sunny and myself and it was
wonderful how many dogs in total we
fostered seven
all the only one at a time never more
than I got to but and we only I mean the
shortest we had one of them was two days
and um the very first one we had
uh was an extraordinary dog beautiful
sensitive it would look you right
straight into the eyes and [__] its head
on one side and I you I could feel him
trying to connect with me you know and
uh it's it's so I I do what I can to
to help the ones who need help and uh
you know
um you've lived just in absolutely
extraordinary life and you know you did
a wonderful job with the book it's it's
wildly entertaining it's a very
difficult book to put down the stories
are just absolutely legendary so well
done in that regard I I love it and I
know you're about to embark on quite the
book tour so you're gonna be doing a lot
of Media stuff
um I guess you know I'm curious about
what it is that you want people to take
from the book but also just your life
like what is instructive about the
experiences that you've had and the
lessons that you've learned as you
reflect back as an 83 year old man on
what's important what's not and and and
and and maybe even a guiding principle
or two that we could incorporate into
our own lives
well they come down to things that I am
still working on
um and it's awkward being a leading
actor
on television and film
um but being brave
being open
being
sensitive to other people tuning into
them becomes more and more and more
important to me
and
I find that in the close friends that I
have
that is their relationship with me too
and it's a wonderful wonderful
experience
um
I
I wish I could go back
there are things I would like to say to
my parents
and my brothers both of them
that I never said
and that makes me very very sad
that I never told them
what they gave me but this gives you an
opportunity to at least say publicly
yeah it kind of does yes yeah I mean
my first draft of this book was over 700
pages
and it's now about 440.
so
people are saying so what are you going
to write next and I say no no no no no
no there's no next this is is there and
then the other day I thought hmm
um
maybe I could find that draft that's got
350 words in it that are all in my book
the director's cut I like the director's
cut yeah yeah
um to your point that was beautifully
shared thank you uh there's a a section
in the book that that I found quite
moving
which was about your
relationship with vulnerability as an
actor and how that's a tool and a
vehicle for unlocking truth but also as
as a um a way of being in the world
right the the the power that comes with
allowing yourself to be vulnerable on
stage but also with the people that you
care about yes yes yes that's
um
perhaps the primary objective in my life
now
to be vulnerable with those you care
about yes
yes
I think that's a beautiful place to end
it
thank you you're a uh you're you're a uh
you're an international gift to humanity
I just wanted to recognize you for
the work that you do of course
um and this beautiful book that you're
putting out into the world I I wish you
much success with it but really how how
you comport yourself as a man in the
world like I find it to be extremely
aspirational and the way that you are so
open-hearted and and
um and Earnest with your feelings and
your friendships uh I think is is is is
is uh is a guidepost for someone like
myself so thank you for that and uh I
love I loved having the opportunity to
meet you and talk to you thank you I've
messed up at times we all have and I
hold on to them I don't let them go I
don't let them control me of course but
they're there
and that was part of who I have been
and in a little tiny way still is and uh
so that
helps me to
reinforce the close relationships that I
already have
that's so important I hope that you can
find
a little bit more grace and forgiveness
for yourself I think you owe that to
yourself
thank you you're welcome thank you very
much for that last comment yeah
and with that
thank you sir
[Music]
that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at ritual.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power away as well as the
plant power meal planner at
meals.richeral.com if you'd like to
support the podcast the easiest and most
impactful thing you can do is to
subscribe to the show on Apple podcasts
on Spotify and on YouTube and leave a
review and or comment
supporting the sponsors who support the
show is also important and appreciated
and sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at richroll.com
today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason camiolo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel Solis thank
you Georgia Whaley for copywriting and
website management and of course our
theme music was created by Tyler Pyatt
Trapper piatt and Harry Mathis
appreciate the love love the support
be back here soon
plants
[Music]
okay